we are in an epidemic of big erexia men
descending into the equivalent of
anorexia looking in the mirror and
seeing what isn't you the end result
Cardiff High Street is full of people
that look like they were made by the
X-Men These Are Meant injecting
themselves this is big eraxia in action
if I ask these men they say back to me
Russ you don't understand it's what a
bird wants it's what women want
sometimes they drop into Morse code
testosterone I don't presume to
understand what women want but mostly
gentlemen the primary characteristic
that a woman is looking for is a man
that isn't an ass I've never used
steroids myself really Poirot but my dad
did my dad massively used steroids he
injected it he lifted massively heavy
weights heart attack boom gone very sad
the only upside I can now do stand up
about it and pay my mortgage